why was megan fox given the boot from
the transformers franchise and how come
we don't hear much from alex pettifer
anymore here are some actors who made
decisions that torpedoed their careers
in a matter of moments
randy quaid's decades-long resume boasts
work from gut-busting comedies like the
national lampoon's vacation films and
kingpin to critically acclaim dramas
like brokeback mountain sure not all his
movies were prestigious just try to
watch pluto nash nowadays but he was
talented enough to nab himself an oscar
nomination for his supporting role in
1973's the last detail so how did it all
go so wrong in september 2009 quaid and
his wife evie were arrested for not
paying a 10 000 hotel bill they were
soon arrested again for squatting in a
home they no longer owned so they
skipped town and headed to canada though
people assumed the quaids were on the
run from the law they claimed they fled
to the north to avoid the hollywood star
whackers a secret organization that
supposedly assassinated celebrities or
manufactured scandals to discredit them
why quaid would be on the top of their
list no one knows but the fugitive actor
told the vancouver press that heath
ledger david carradine and chris penn
were the latest victims of the insidious
cabal aside from his bizarre role in the
2018 indie film all you can eat quaid
hasn't made any film appearances since
the late 2000s
when your resume features starring roles
in ferris bueller's day off and dirty
dancing you must be an 80s darling with
a fantastic career ahead of you jennifer
gray played the role of jeannie bueller
in the john hughes classic and starred
in dirty dancing as the baby that no one
is supposed to put in the corner matthew
broderick and patrick swayze did just
fine later on but whatever happened to
jennifer gray as grey's career began to
slow down in the early 90s she made the
decision to get a nose job while the
operation didn't have any medical
complications it left gray nearly
unrecognizable in a career where being
recognized is everything casting calls
were made much more difficult now that
she wasn't being immediately remembered
for her iconic roles gray told the
mirror in 2012 it was the nose job from
hell i'll always be this once famous
actress nobody recognizes because of a
nose job decades after dirty dancing's
release gray reflected on showing her
daughter the film and being open about
her medical history she said you know
your face looked really different in the
movie you looked really beautiful i said
yeah i said but the problem was
i didn't believe enough in myself
while she never again reached the mega
star status she had in the 1980s gray
found work off and on in the 2000s and
beyond settling into a solid career as a
character actor she's guest starred on
shows like grey's anatomy house and
phineas and ferb and was part of the
ensemble cast of the amazon original
series red oaks
wesley snipes was at the top of his game
when he starred in white men can't jump
to wong fu thanks for everything julie
newmar and of course the blade trilogy
then he decided to not pay his taxes now
it's obvious that not paying your taxes
is bad but what's the worst that could
happen you pay it off plus some fines
and do demolition man too to make your
cash back not for snipes his offenses
were so bad that he got jailed for them
in 2008 snipes was found guilty of
willfully not filing taxes for three
years and was sentenced to a year in the
slammer for each year he failed to make
a trip to h r block along with 17
million dollars in fines and penalties
since it's pretty hard to film blade 4
from a cell snipe's career came to a
crashing halt by the time he was
released the world had mostly moved on
with scandals receding from the
collective memory and groundswell of
nostalgia for his iconic roles in 90s
movies particularly as the vampire
hunting vampire blade snipes is slowly
staging a 2020s comeback he recently
starred alongside kevin hart in netflix
true story made a cameo over skype on
what we do in the shadows and stole all
of his scenes in the long-awaited sequel
to coming to america
stand-up comics can rehearse their
routines all they want but one thing
that's nearly impossible to prepare for
is the influence of hecklers when
michael richards of seinfeld fame found
himself in a battle of wits with a
member of his audience during a live
show in 2006 he made a split-second
decision that destroyed his career in an
instant richards responded to the man's
criticism with a series of racial slurs
demanding that the african-american
customer be thrown out of the hollywood
laugh factory a video of the incident
quickly found its way online showing
richard stopping his show mid-monologue
and turning his ire to the audience
member there were audible gasps in the
room as the incensed actor then
repeatedly used the n-word despite the
man shouting back that the language was
uncalled for richards then left the
stage without finishing his routine
richards appeared via satellite on the
late show with david letterman to
apologize for his outburst telling the
nation that he was deeply sorry about
what happened and insisting that he
wasn't actually a racist it didn't do
him any good though his career sense has
been limited to the occasional tv
appearance often alongside jerry
seinfeld whenever someone brings up
brendan fraser in conversation someone
will almost always ask something like
why doesn't hollywood cast him anymore
the american canadian graduated from
character actor to leading man when he
appeared as the swashbuckling rick
o'connell in the mummy the first film in
a trilogy that has come to define his
career the franchise came to an
unspectacular end in 2008 but frazier
struck further gold when another of his
films released that year became an
unexpected hit the 3d fantasy adventure
journey to the center of the earth
returned a worldwide box office total of
240 million dollars from a budget of 60
million dollars reaffirming frasier's
position as a genuine leading man
unfortunately this was where frazier
would take a wrong turn in a monumental
era of judgment the star turned down the
chance to reprise his role in the sequel
journey to the mysterious island content
with the work he had done in
extraordinary measures and fury
vengeance fraser felt comfortable
letting the role go to dwayne the rock
johnson but when his films became two of
the biggest box office bombs of 2010 it
became clear that he had made the wrong
choice
journey 2 went on to surpass the
original raking in an impressive 335
million dollars
that was when frazier's career really
slowed down as he put it to sway there's
a time in anyone's career when the phone
stops ringing
in 2018 a comeback labeled by cultured
vultures as the renaissance began with
frazier landing roles on tv series the
affair trust and doom patrol in short
order while promoting one of his new
projects frazier explained to gq that
his career had been on a downswing
because of professional retaliation from
the hollywood foreign press association
the organization that awards the golden
globes frazier alleged that he'd once
been assaulted by hfpa president philip
burke frazier's career is looking up in
the 2020s with an upcoming role as
firefly in the dc comics movie batgirl
he's also working with several of
hollywood's most acclaimed directors
including darren aronofsky for the whale
and martin scorsese for killers of the
flower moon
tila tequila nuen began her questionable
path to fame by becoming one of the
earliest recognized social media
celebrities graduating from the most
popular person on myspace to one of the
most unpopular media personalities in
recent history in 2007 mtv saw fit to
capitalize on tequila's online presence
by giving her a dating show a shot at
love with tila tequila and she made her
first film appearance that same year as
a hooters girl and i now pronounce you
chuck and larry that same year it all
came crashing down when people noticed
some bizarre posts on her website
sympathizing with adolf hitler tequila
said that she had and we quote
learned the truth about the war and
insinuated that the nazi dictator was
merely misunderstood tequila attempted
to get her career back on track in 2015
by participating in the uk reality show
celebrity big brother but she was booted
out of the house when showrunners
learned of her nazi sympathizing the
disgraced internet personality has since
tried and failed to release a gospel
album and has been embroiled in a
custody battle for her child
being under the spotlight is second
nature for lindsay lohan who began
working as a child model when she was
just 3 years old when her recurring role
on the soap opera another world got her
noticed by executives at disney she was
doubly cast in the 1998 remake of the
parent trap which turned out to be a
surprise hit for the company the
red-headed actress became a teen
sensation in the years that followed
finding further success with freaky
friday herbie fully loaded and mean
girls
unfortunately lohan's hot streak would
come to an abrupt halt in 2007.
on may 26 lohan was rushed to the
hospital after getting into a car
accident in beverly hills the actress
had recently been discharged from the
wonderland center rehab facility in los
angeles for undisclosed problems but the
nature of these issues became all too
clear when lohan was charged with dui
possession of cocaine and misdemeanor
hit and run following the incident if
her career wasn't already damaged enough
it certainly was when she was arrested
on the same charges just two months
later that was just the beginning of a
string of car crashes arrests and stints
at rehab that would make lohan a
commonly mocked figure by the media the
severity of her downfall was highlighted
by the critical response to her next
film the widely panned i know who killed
me in this flick lohan once again takes
on two roles at once but this time her
performances won her multiple accolades
at the 2008 golden raspberry awards the
film took home a record eight razzies in
total
lohan's career isn't over though at the
time of this video's release in 2022
she's set to star in the festive netflix
film falling for christmas playing a
snobby heiress stricken with amnesia
bow-tied man-child pee-wee herman was
huge during the 1980s the subject of two
feature films and an emmy-winning
children's tv series however public
perception of the once beloved character
and the man behind him paul rubins
changed drastically in 1991 during a
visit with his parents in sarasota
florida rubens was arrested for indecent
exposure at an adult movie theater with
sheriff's deputies claiming that they
spotted him touching himself during the
film the actor who was 38 at the time
pleaded no contest and agreed to take
part in a new anti-drug campaign to
avoid a trial on the misdemeanor charge
peewee toys were pulled from shells
across the nation as reubens retreated
from the public eye entirely
disappearing for the remainder of the
90s reuben's attempted comeback at the
turn of the century was quickly thwarted
when more charges of a sexual nature
were brought against him acting on a tip
officers raided rubin's home and seized
thousands of items from a collection of
vintage gay erotica some of which
depicted minors in the nude rubens has
always denied that he owned any sexual
images of children but acknowledged that
since he tended to buy his collectibles
in bulk he could have possessed some
questionable material without even
realizing it regardless the tatters of
his reputation went up in flames it took
another decade before rubin's dared
return to the character for peewee's big
holiday on netflix the positive response
to his comeback is scant consolation for
a man who spent most of his career in
hiding because of a few serious lapses
in judgment
the scandal that led to the damaging of
ingrid bergman's career wasn't too
outrageous by 21st century standards but
the consequences of the affair lingered
through the rest of the actress's life
the star of casablanca and gaslight was
expected to be a typical woman of the
time married and happy to serve her
husband but in reality she was a free
spirit who wanted to sleep around just
like all her male co-stars did during
her marriage to neurosurgeon peter
lindstrom bergman began an affair with
roberto rosellini her director on
stramboli bergman loved rosalini and
when she got pregnant with his child she
left lindstrom and their daughter to run
off with the italian director while a
woman having an affair and divorcing her
daughter's father seems pretty tame
compared to the exploits of tila tequila
the america of 1950 was freaked out the
fervor went all the way to washington
when senator edwin c johnson proposed a
bill that would require movies to be
approved not just based on the moral
content of the film itself but the moral
character of the people involved in
their creation
johnson who had once considered bergman
his favorite actress claimed that
bergman was influencing americans
towards evil and tried to have her
banned from appearing in any future
american films bergman stayed out of the
country for eight years
and although she continued to work in
the industry her star status was
permanently damaged by an affair of the
heart
kiss me kiss miss if it were the last
time
once upon a time amanda bynes was on the
rise but that was a long time ago the
star of the amanda show and she's the
man ran afoul of drugs and alcoholic
many child stars before her but what
truly killed her career was her complete
and total twitter meltdown in the weeks
after her arrest bind's 2012 tweet storm
featured the actress requesting sex from
rapper drake calling miley cyrus and
jay-z ugly and even blaming rihanna for
the domestic abuse she faced at the
hands of chris brown in the real world
she apparently set a driveway on fire
also igniting her own pants in the
process binds was eventually diagnosed
with bipolar disorder and twice placed
in a psychiatric facility she hasn't
acted since 2010's easy a years later a
seemingly reformed binds is still trying
to regroup and repair her life much like
britney spears binds has recently made
headlines again for speaking up against
her conservatorship which was court
ordered during her personal struggles in
2013.
in march 2022 a judge in california
ruled to end the conservatorship after
nearly a decade
paula deen was once everyone's favorite
southern cooking show mama a butter
loving lady who loved good food and
wanted you to love it too dean's success
led to stints on shows like top chef
master chef and even a bonafide acting
role in cameron crowe's elizabethtown by
2012 however the dean empire had all but
crumbled thanks to its empress being
pretty racist in 2012 dean was sued by a
former general manager of one of her
restaurants claiming she regularly threw
around the n-word during work and wanted
to stage a southern themed wedding with
black men playing slaves in testimony
during the trial dean essentially
admitted to everything confirming her
use of the slur and admitting that she
thought the idea of a slave wedding was
quote beautiful once her statements were
verified food network reacted swiftly
refusing to renew her contract despite
multiple public apologies that doesn't
mean that dean is out of the game for
good though her attempted comeback has
involved an appearance on dancing with
the stars the occasional appearance on
fox and friends and a guest judge spot
on gordon ramsay's master chef usa
in a career spanning the better part of
70 years robert blake went from the
child star of mgm's little rascals to
the enigmatic mystery man in lost
highway unfortunately his role in the
mind-bending david lynch film wherein he
plays an entity who induces a man to
kill his wife would be his last before
the murder of his real-life wife in
2001. on may 4th 2001 bonnie lee bakely
was found shot dead in blake's car which
was parked around the corner from the
studio city restaurant the couple ate at
that night blake claimed that he had
returned to the restaurant to collect
his missing gun when the fatal shooting
of his wife took place although a police
investigation determined that blake's
missing gun was not the one used to kill
bakely blake was arrested in 2002 when
two former stuntmen came forward
claiming that the actor had tried to
hire them both to murder his wife on
separate occasions blake was eventually
acquitted three years later but a later
civil court claim later found him guilty
of intentionally causing bakeley's death
and ordered him to pay 30 million
dollars to bakeley's children blick's
criminal trial was the nail in his
career coffin but that didn't stop the
senior actor from issuing a plea to
producers in the aftermath he proclaimed
himself broke and announced that he was
available for work unsurprisingly work
never came
the 1980 season was a transitional one
for saturday night live with the
remainder of its original cast departing
in favor of a new group of comedians
including eddie murphy joe piscapo and
charles rocket producer gene domanium
apparently thought rocket would be her
breakout star an actor in comic in the
mold of snl alzheimer's bill murray and
chevy chase rocket indeed made a name
for himself on snl with the rocket
report a cheeky series of pre-taped man
on the street bits but it was a live
blunder that did him in in a parody of
the who shot jr craze on dallas a
reference to guest hosts and dallas
co-star charlene tilton an unknown
fictional assassin shot rocket in an
abrupt conclusion to the sketch at the
end of the episode with the entire cast
gathered on stage tilton asked rocket
how he was doing
charlie how are you feeling after you've
been shot oh man it's the first time
i've been shot in my life i'd like to
know
within weeks rocket was fired from snl
due to the language he used he went on
to have a modest movie career usually
playing yuppies jerks and dads and
things like earth girls are easy hocus
pocus and dumb and dumber but nothing
approaching the resumes of murray and
chase tragically rocket died by suicide
in 2005 at age 56.
a major star of the silent film era
roscoe fatty arbuckle was at the height
of his fame when hollywood's first major
scandal permanently derailed his life
and career on september 5th 1921 the
actor and comedian booked three rooms at
the saint francis hotel where he was
planning on throwing a party an aspiring
actress named virginia rapp was one of
several women who were extended in
invitation but her decision to accept
would prove to be a fatal one rap was
eventually found seriously ill in room
1219 the room arbuckle was sleeping in
after allegedly telling people arbuckle
had hurt her she died four days later of
a ruptured bladder arbuckle was arrested
and charged with manslaughter but the
jury failed to reach a verdict and a
mistrial was called after a second trial
yielded the same result arbuckle's legal
team stepped up their defense making
sure that the third one went in their
favor although the actor was eventually
acquitted it was too late his career was
over his films were banned and his
legacy was left in tatters
playing michaela baines in 2007's
transformers made megan fox an overnight
sensation
within a couple of years she'd return
for the sequel transformers revenge of
the fallen starred as the titular
jennifer in the cult [ __ ] comedy
jennifer's body and played a supporting
role in how to lose friends and alienate
people unfortunately for the rising star
she was about to lose some friends and
alienate plenty of people herself in
2009 fox sat down for an interview with
the uk magazine wonderland when asked a
softball question about working with
transformers director michael bay fox
answered honestly and provocatively
saying he's like napoleon and he wants
to create this insane infamous madman
reputation fox's historical comparisons
weren't done though as she continued he
wants to be like hitler on his sets and
he is despite the extremely unflattering
comparison base still wanted to rehire
fox for transformers dark of the moon
however he was reportedly overruled by
producer steven spielberg who directed
schindler's list and founded the
survivors of the showa visual history
foundation
fox's team denied reports that she'd
been ousted stating that she'd left the
project of her own volition but the
damage was done ever since fox has
appeared in a couple of teenage mutant
ninja turtle movies a few episodes of
new girl and a music video for her
fiance machine gun kelly
gilbert gottfried was something of a
minor pop culture icon in the 1980s and
early 1990s after a one-season stint on
saturday night live in the early 80s he
popped up in numerous comedy movies and
tv shows including beverly hills cop 2
the adventures of fort fairlane and the
problem child trilogy even if you didn't
know his face you definitely knew his
voice an abrasive grating rasp that
served him well as a voice actor
godfrey's most iconic voice roles were
both birds he played iago the parrot in
disney's aladdin and the aflac duck in a
series of iconic insurance commercials
off-screen gottfried made much of his
living as a relentlessly touring club
comedian it was in that mode where
gottfried issued some remarks that
ripped tremendous damage on his career
and reputation when a devastating
earthquake and tsunami hit japan in 2011
killing at least 3 000 people gottfried
was quick to tweet out a dozen dark
one-liners among them japan is really
advanced they don't go to the beach the
beach comes to them twitter users called
out gottfried for what they felt was bad
taste and questionable judgment while
the comedian's bosses at aflac gave him
the boot aflac cmo michael zuna told the
ap there is no place for anything but
compassion and concern during these
difficult times on april 12 2022 gilbert
godfrey passed away at the age of 67.
despite having only a few credits to his
name alex pettifer was on track to
become one of the first breakout stars
of the 2010s
his movie magic mic was one of the most
talked about films of the year earning
critical praise and making over 100
million dollars on a seven million
dollar budget however just before the
release of pedifer's i am number four
the hollywood reporter ran an expose
detailing the actor's misconduct on the
set of that film and on another upcoming
film beastly rather than do damage
control pettifer doubled down on the
animosity in an interview with v-man the
actor called los angeles a hole
continuing i think it's this insidious
pool where nearly everyone lives in fear
of his profession he likened acting to a
prison sentence quipping you go you
serve your time you try to replicate
johnny depp's career and then you move
to paris the actor later admitted that
the interview may had led to a rift with
his magic mike co-star channing tatum
whether or not the two still have beef
today pettifer wasn't invited back from
magic mike xxl and he's been relegated
to supporting roles in relatively
obscure projects ever since
clinton spillsbury only made two brief
tv appearances before securing the title
role in the big screen adventure the
legend of the lone ranger the reason
because he looked good in the
character's iconic mask producer martin
starger told entertainment weekly we had
to find an actor whose eyes were not
close together despite his
well-proportioned face spillsbury had no
experience with fame during the media
circuit leading up to the 1981 release
of the movie spillsbury agreed to a
meeting with andy warhol proprietor of
interview magazine in the andy warhol
diaries the famed artist wrote that the
actor had made some rather personal
admissions about his sexuality while
drunk spillsbury fell in love with
dennis christopher and then with that
kid bud court who was in herald and mod
then he said he'd been picked up by
fashion designer halston and woke up in
bed with him apart from that odd bit of
press spillsbury was apparently
difficult to work with the inexperienced
actor needed dialogue cuts because he
couldn't remember his lines to the point
that the producers eventually had to dub
him over with someone entirely different
the legend of the lone ranger flopped at
the box office earning 12.6 million
dollars and quickly disappearing from
theaters spillsbury disappeared too he'd
never act in another movie or tv series
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one